Bronk ransom that you have you been
right thirty years yes not yet
close very 2029 you you tell a story of
young love I think you were on your
honeymoon in Europe yes and you were on
a was it you were driving but on a train
we went to our travel agent to talk
about this we were mid-30s when we got
married and we knew that we wanted to
start a family so this was like it we
wanted this honeymoon to be really
spectacular spent five weeks in Europe
and it was all so we started in
Switzerland we're gonna rent a car and
then go to Italy and the travel agent
says oh by the way instead of driving
around the Alps up and over you take a
train is a flatbed car it takes three
cars bumper to bumper on a flatbed car
and then they put you know you and then
you go through the Alps by the way he
says wink wink
there are three tunnels the first tunnel
is about five minutes the second tunnel
is about eight to ten minutes
the third tunnel is 50 minutes long if
you're a honeymooner and I said say so I
told my wife and she exhaled and said
okay we're on the train there's a van in
front of us with a bunch of Italian
families in front and behind us I mean
as close as you are I can see the people
behind us two couples two Italian
couples and so we we start going and we
go into the end it's a massive
experience emotionally and physically
and the wind is whipping through in its
pitch dark you cannot see well and it's
it's fascinating and we come out of the
tunnel into the station and I say to
Robin that's one we start again we go
through the second it's dark can't see
anything we come out of it that's to
start the third tunnel wait till it's
absolutely pitch dark here we go it's a
small rental with a stick shift and I am
like trying to get my trousers off she
is trying to lower her chair and we
can't see in that you cannot see
anything so it's all by feel amazing one
thing I learned for sure is that never
be completely nude when transferring
from one seat over the stick shift
keep your trousers on and do it
afterward and II can't see funny I would
recommend it but that's it
[Applause]
so we are in flagrante as they say and I
don't know where to put my hands or
something and my wife is just come on
just you know now what's happening is
that my eyes are adjusting I can see her
profiles beautiful woman
love her with all my heart and I could
see her and Ed's or her pretty face and
it's great and I think the eyes are
getting no the eyes aren't getting used
to total pitch-black what happened is
that we were coming to a station imagine
I'm like this
[Laughter]
I can see the the two couples the
Italian couples in in the car behind us
with their wine
and the women ago stopped I'd stop it
and my wife says those three words to
you every husband wants to hear get off
so I get off the Italian family the the
grandmothers turning they're struggling
to put the trousers back and I never
found that we never found out if this
was a gag if he would if this travel
agent did this on purpose
knew all along it wasn't 50 minutes it
was more like 15
[Applause]
[Music]